what's the difference between the causal
graph and the multi-way graph is one
a transitive reduction of the other are
they the same no no they're different
kinds of things so
so
you have this prop okay so that there
are many kinds of graphs oh look there
we go there's a nice this is a multi-way
or a causal that's a causal graph that
that thing is a causal graph
so
okay sorry there are a lot of kinds of
graphs running around that's right
that's fine and each one of these nodes
represents a hypergraph in and of itself
and then these lines represent updating
rules that's that's a causal graph so
that that's a no each one of those nodes
represents an event an updating event
so what happens is okay let's let's go
through the kinds of graphs
so
first kind of graph is the spatial
hypograph that represents the structure
of space
its nodes are atoms of space
its hyperedges are relations between
atoms of space
okay
and at any moment in time
you can imagine
that you've taken a slice representing
the current moment in time there is a
spatial hypergraph that represents the
structure of the universe
okay so that's first first level of
graph the second thing is that graph
then evolves and it evolves by
events
that take a particular
set of hyper edges
combine them together and produce
another set of hyper edges or another
some set of atoms of space that produces
another set of atoms of space so it's
like a you're running all these little
functions you've got you've got this
this spatial hypograph and it's got all
these all this it's like a big data
structure with lots of um
lots of pieces in it and they're these
functions that are running on particular
parts of that data structure to produce
uh new uh
pieces of a new data structure every
update event that's an event so the
causal graph
is the network of causal relationships
between those updating events
so why are there why are those updating
events connected well the reason they're
connected is because a particular
updating event needs something as input
it needs to use certain hyperedges
certain atoms of space as its input and
the question is are those hyperedges up
to date do they have those and so
there's a a set of causal relationships
between these updating events
where one updating event
can uh it has
it is
it has a
it has a causal dependence on a previous
updating event so you get this this
graph that connects that represents the
causal relationships between updating
events that's a directed graph
uh if you go from one event and you
follow its arrows you're basically going
into events that are in the future so
those arrows represent a time-like path
just following those arrows is a
possible time-like path
so you can also ask um two events
could they happen at the same time
so there are events that couldn't
possibly happen at the same time because
they are they're in a chain one
following from another in a timeline
sequence so those couldn't possibly
happen at the same time there's no
reference frame there's no assignment of
simultaneity which will allow those
things to happen at the same time so
what what can occur
is that but in this it's a partially
ordered set of updating events
and in that post set there are
things where you can have two updating
events which can be considered to happen
at the same time you can have a
reference frame where those two updating
events could happen happen you say they
happen at the same time you couldn't do
that
if they were in a chain one after the
other but you can do that if they're in
what in postset language is an
anti-chain
yeah
a doodle correspond to the different
lines that are separating
which i imagine
they're separating into quote-unquote
branches of space possible
that's a possible foliation of that
causal graph so what that means is
that that is a possible choice of what
updating events should be considered
simultaneous to what other ones and just
like in relativity theory there are
multiple different possible foliations
of space-time so there are multiple
different
uh choices of what you consider to be
simultaneous so to speak
and that
that's the um
so the causal graph
okay the the
the ordinary causal graph is the network
of causal relationships between updating
events
in space
or in space time
now okay so that's that's one level of
graph
the other the next thing that we can
talk about is the multi-way graph and
then
not to sound too confusing but there's
also a multi-way causal graph um ah ah
okay okay and the multi-way causal graph
is just so you know stephen i i read
virtually each one of the archive papers
and for some reason this is a sticking
point for me what's the causal graph
versus the multi-way graph are they the
same well they're defined in the same
document so it'd be unlikely i i wrote
this kind of technical introduction to
our project where i have an appendix
that simply lists all the different
kinds of graphs because i knew people
and one of the things that was you know
there's a practicality of doing a big
project like this you know there was a
funny moment when we did the colors for
all these graphs because what we
realized is you know you're just drawing
all these graphs and you see one of
these graphs and it's like what on earth
is this and we realized if we have
consistent coloring of these different
graphs at least as soon as you see a
graph you say
i mean we we kind of joke that there's
this color we call branchial pink which
is the color of our branchial graphs
which is yet another kind of we haven't
even talked about yet
um but uh you know the the um
uh the causal graph we have you know the
events are in yellow the edges are in
brown the spatial graph it's all sort of
blue um and the multi-way graph well
let's talk about the multi-way graph so
the multi-way graph
in the simplest form
the nodes of the multi-way graph are
complete states of the universe
so the paths in the multi-ray graph
correspond to possible histories for the
whole universe
now that's what we might call the global
multi-way graph
um there's been a big effort max
piskanov has been the main one sort of
pushing this to have these things we can
call local multi-way graphs
they're hard to understand but they're
important and they will help us to
understand quantum field theory a lot
but they just
they're there but the global multi-way
graph every node is a complete state of
the universe
and
so
so then the multi-way causal graph
is asking of those complete states of
the universe
what are the causal relationships
between
uh between those those states of the
universe and that gives us the multi-way
causal graph and the the ordinary
multi-way of the ordinary causal graph
is a is a is a kind of a slice of the
multi-way causal graph so the multi-way
causal graph represents the set of
causal relationships including
both
things that could happen at different
places in space
and things that can happen on different
branches of history so one talks about
events being time-like separated that is
one they follow from each other in time
another possibility is that they're
space-like separated that is those
events correspond could correspond to
the same time but they are separated in
space there's a third possibility which
is they can be branch-like separated
which means that they are occurring on
different branches of quantum history
and so there's all three of those time
like separation space like separation
branch-like separation
in the multi-way causal graph all three
kinds of separation occur
and um the the question of which one
uh
you know any two events can be both
space-like separated and branch-like
separated or they can be just
branch-like separated and so on and uh
that's a
that object the multi-way causal graph
okay so for the spatial hypograph we
believe that it's continuum limit when
you look at a large number of nodes is
like ordinary space it's like a manifold
it's like um uh for the
uh for the multi for the ordinary causal
graph it's the same kind of thing it's
like a minkowski space it's like the
space
you probably know that that ordinary you
know something like euclidean space
has this feature that you can move one
way you can move back you know every
every path you can go down you can you
can reverse it and go the other way
right that's a feature of ordinary space
i can move this way i can move that way
in space time that's not how it works we
get to go forwards in time we don't get
to go backwards in time and so that
corresponds to the limit the limiting
structure is not euclidean space but a
minkowski space and so that's the same
kind of thing with our causal graph
the limiting structure is a minkowski
signature space that is it can be in
general a curved space just like in
general relativity
the multi-way causal graph we don't
understand very well yet what its
continuum limit is it's a it's a weird
kind of minkowski-like hilbert space
interesting and um it it uh a special
case of it is probably twister space
which is um uh this
idea that's this kind of neat trick with
complex numbers that roger penrose
invented back in the 1960s as a way to
understand um
uh well to think about sort of quantum
mechanics and space time and so on but
it's it's a that seems to be a special
case of the multi-way causal graph but
there's a there needs to be a
generalization of that made to be able
to um uh to see how to um to see what
that continuum limit looks like
and and we can keep going and it's
things get wilder i mean we start
talking about um
oh well i mean the the
yeah i mean there are a lot of kinds of
graphs running around here